why do you say that most movie ideas are
very simple well i think movies tend to
be based on really simple stories um one
of the things that newer writers
can end up doing without realizing it is
over complicating their stories right
because they feel like
especially if they start writing without
a solid outline and they kind of get
stuck they feel like oh i have to add
more complications to give me more story
to write and they'll end up making
things overly complex
where you know the movies that we tend
to see are pretty straightforward
stories they're
you know a concise setup
some good escalations in the middle and
then a wrap it up in the end
and it's the execution that makes things
entertaining and interesting right so
it's it's not that we need very complex
stories
in movies a lot of times overly complex
stories will be kind of hard to follow a
little bit bloated you know it'll be
hard to kind of really go deep in a
character's experience in a story that
has too many complications or too many
characters uh whereas
typically in movies what we see is like
you know one person pursuing one thing
and what's interesting or entertaining
about it is the way that that sort of is
executed
the interesting cinematic you know cool
stuff that happens along that journey
which is actually a pretty simple
journey um but it allows us the kind of
space to dive into how that character is
transforming
the emotional experience of it and kind
of like the the you know cool cinematic
stuff that happens along the way
does a simple idea mean a boring
screenplay
no i i don't think so um i think most if
you look at most movies it's actually a
very simple
storyline right it's a it's a pretty
straightforward you know one person
trying to achieve one thing
i think
a lot of times newer writers maybe worry
that their stories are too simple and
that will make them boring
but
if you have a simple story that just
gives you a
a nice sturdy framework to tell your
story and then it gives you the sort of
space and the freedom to find the
entertaining moments and cool stuff in
the execution of that story if that
makes sense
right i know you've said and i don't
know if it was it was in the book or in
an interview that the cliche of sort of
like the the pretty but doesn't know it
or the hot mess
that sort of is rescued you know right
that that's been done so much and i i
agree um but what if somebody really
needs to stick to
the rom-com where high school reunion
and best friends getting married and
does anybody object but they want to do
the next memento or they want to do the
next crash something that takes a little
more putting together and you guide them
and say maybe you're not totally ready
for that yet yeah i think that that is a
challenge right um
you know
some there are some stories that are
i don't know if i would call them more
complex but the the execution of them is
more advanced right like crash is
intersecting story lines kind of all put
together within the structure of a
feature film
um
i would call that like an you know sort
of advanced craft kind of movie right um
so i don't think that that's uh
necessarily an overly complicated story
at all and there definitely are newer
writers who who love movies like that
and who want to write something like
that and that's what's inspiring them
and sort of getting them in front of the
computer to write it
i certainly wouldn't discourage them i
do think that um
you know when you're learning it's going
to be easier
to learn and to to sort of understand or
wrap your brain around like how to put a
screenplay together if you work with a
simpler story or a more um
sort of straightforward mainstream kind
of story with one main character who's
sort of pursuing one
main goal in the story that'll be easier
just to learn on um if that makes sense
like when you're learning to drive a car
you know if you learn on an automatic
that's a little bit easier than like
learning how to shift and learning how
to drive at the same time um not that it
can't be done but it just might take a
little bit longer right um might take a
little more patience um
so so yeah i think that
if you're if you have the desire to
write something like crash or like
memento
if you are willing to be patient with
yourself
and give yourself the time to sort of
figure out how to write that particular
screenplay then great you know different
people are motivated by different things
so if that's what's going to get you to
show up and keep trying and keep
learning your craft then go for it um it
just know that it might be a longer
process because you're sort of learning
lots of different skill sets at the same
time and learning how to write a
screenplay is already a bunch of
different skill sets you know sort of
put together
um so that's just adding a little bit
more to your plate but it it can be done
for sure
sure i love that analogy so the driving
the car so it's like learning to drive
in your dad's old station wagon versus
some sporty little
foreign model with a clutch on a hill
right right exactly and you've never
driven before and you have all these
people behind you honking so yeah that
that makes sense yeah
yeah but if you're in that situation i
mean if that's what um sort of
inspires you to learn how to drive right
then then go for it and just know that
you're going to have to be
you know sort of gentle on yourself and
and patient with yourself because it's
it's probably going to be
you know frustrating but if you love the
story that's okay you might have the
patience to kind of get through that
right
do you think audiences though really
resonate more with simple stories or no
as long as it's a well-told story yeah i
think as long as it's a well-told story
um i think simple stories um the the
benefit that that maybe they offer to
audiences and to writers too is that
they
you know when i say a simple story i
mean sort of like the the plot framework
is fairly straightforward um and
what you're what you're able to bring to
that as a writer is finding new ways
that
maybe the you know sort of tropes that
we expect from the genre those things
are executed in a new interesting
entertaining you know cinematic sort of
way right so you're bringing your you're
not you're not writing the boring
screenplay um
just to make it easy for yourself you're
you're choosing a story that gives you a
framework that is easy to wrap your
brain around so that you can bring the
creativity to it and add the
entertaining stuff on top of it
and then the other benefit is that you
know with a with a somewhat um
straightforward plot um i don't want to
say it's too straightforward but if with
a simple plot framework that allows you
to then you know come up with the cool
reversals and interesting twists and
turns and all that stuff
um the other thing that you can that
gives you is sort of the space and the
freedom to
develop the character more right because
if you are
taking less time to explain the way the
plot is working or why you know
complications are happening the way they
are it gives you room for the characters
to feel things and to interact with each
other and to transform and be you know
be affected by what they're going
through and it gives you kind of some
space for us to
have that experience along with the
character if that makes sense
it does and i know we've talked about
bridesmaids before and you use it as an
example in the book and what seems like
a simple story when you actually put
these relationship dynamics it's
actually much more complicated yeah very
interesting yeah and that's a good
example i think that bridesmaids is a
simple story right it's a very clear
story framework that they're working
within but they have all these lovely
lovely funny you know set pieces that
are inventive that we haven't seen
before right so that's in the execution
that they're able to kind of you know
they have this sturdy foundation that
they're building on top of but it gives
them the freedom to do really
fun funny entertaining things and we
also because the plot framework is so
sturdy and easy for us to kind of
understand what's happening
um you know you get that character that
is
nicely developed over the entire movie
which you know you might not expect that
in a broad comedy right but there's a
lot of feeling there too she's really
going through something in that story so
yeah there's a lot of levels and and
it's about to uh the outward appearances
yeah and trying to kind of keep up with
friendships and your peer group and
stuff and
so yeah it's a movie that when i first
heard about it i was like yeah that's
not for me and everybody was like oh you
got to see bridesmaids i'm like no and
then i finally saw it and i'm like why
was i resistant to it because it's
excellent yeah that's one of those i can
watch over and over again because it's
so entertaining and there is so much
sort of genuine you know humanity in it
as well so